[Music]
President Obama is traveling the country
did you know this and he spent last
night in Las Vegas yeah yeah this
morning he woke up on his hotel room
floor trying to figure out what to do
about a tiger a baby and 9% unemployment
[Applause]
Mitt Romney of course the news according
to new polls that just came out Mitt
Romney does very well with Republican
voters who make more than $200,000 yeah
or as Romney calls them trailer-trash
can someone live on that how do you do
it they must eat garbage that's nothing
like why Romney sounds but I'm going
with that impression now I like the evil
Romney better than them where's robot
Romney made not to and that's no good
either
in a in an interview listen to this
rapper ice-t called Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton aji meaning gangster
yeah no I says he likes Clinton's policy
with broad consensus on international
problems before hos yeah anyone watch
toddlers and tiaras here
you should go I'm seriously yeah TV is a
gift and you're wasting it yeah
no wow one of the moms from Toddlers and
Tiaras is suing media outlets claiming
they tried to sexualize her daughter
yeah yeah the mom said they turned an
innocent pole dance by a three-year-old
into something dirty a Florida man was
recently arrested for taking upskirt
shots at Walmart yeah it will it will
come to trial as soon as they can find
12 jurors willing to look at upskirt
shots of Walmart shopper
[Music]
Romney's like what is this Walmart is
that even a place make me see I'm
putting them together that's what makes
it beautiful you're gonna like this
eh no I don't know I think you will a
new study shows that when a very
interesting shows that when men perform
oral sex on women it can cause them to
contract mouth cancer later in life yeah
the study also says that according to
women most American men have nothing to
worry about
Taco Bell in the news Taco Bell
[Applause]
I'm gonna get out there goodbye
everybody
[Applause]
like I've went from that joke right to
Taco Bell Taco Bell has introduced a new
breakfast menu yeah
Taco Bell says it's a good idea because
breakfast is the most important bowel
explosion of the day
[Music]
I'm proud of what I do for a living
[Laughter]